prêt alors que joe biden devient le 46e
président des états unis quel bilan
économique tirées des années trump élu
sur un programme populiste promettant de
ramener des emplois au pays donald trump
at il tenu ses promesses
le niveau de vie des américains s'est il
amélioré pendant ces quatre années et
plus généralement dans quel état les
ch'ti de la première économie mondiale à
son successeur
on en parle tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir
bonsoir jacques un bon soir stéphanie
alors jacques ce bilan économique de
donald trump et du trump isme
globalement positif comme on l'a souvent
lu et entendu
alors oui il est clair que le bilan est
plutôt positif même si il faut dire que
cette année la dernière année du mandat
de trump a été quand même terriblement
perturbé par l'aco vide 19
alors oui effectivement c'est donc un
monde c'est donc si vous voulez des
résultats positifs sur la question de la
croissance sur la question du chômage
mais en même temps il faut souligner
qu'il y avait eu dans le mandat de trump
une réforme fiscale extrêmement
avantageuses pour wall street et donc on
peut se demander si donnant run n'a pas
finalement choisi wall street contre
mainstreet ou qu'on essaie cette
expression américaine qui veut dire
choisir les milliardaires contre l'homme
de la rue alors un jacques comment les
américains jugent utiles ces années
trump sur le plan justement de
l'économie c'est ça qui est extrêmement
intéressant c'est de voir que les
jugements sur l'économie et donc sur
donald trump dépens de tout à fait de
l'appartenance partisane des gens et on
l'a vu avec les sondages de sortie des
urnes
après l'élection présidentielle si vous
voulez les gens qui considéraient que
l'économie américaine était florissante
et bien ils ont voté à 78 %
pour donald trump les gens qui
considéraient que l'économie était
plutôt en crise ils ont voté pour 80%
pour joe biden même chose si vous voulez
les gens qui considèrent globalement que
leur situation que que l'économie va
bien et bien est ce sont des gens qui
ont plutôt voté pour donald train et les
gens
qui n'ont pas considérer que l'économie
était quelque chose d'important pour les
choix qu'ils avaient fait en termes de
président eh bien ils ont plutôt voté
pour diouf hayden donc en réalité cette
question de l'économie elle est aussi
une forme de division entre les
électeurs de train et les électeurs de
joe biden alors à ce que ce jugement
avait conforté par les faits oui tout à
fait alors si on regarde le taux de
croissance
il est évident que au moins dans les
trois premières années de son mandat
donald trump à assurer une croissance
plutôt supérieurs à ce qu'avait eu ses
prédécesseurs
alors si vous voulez il y avait eu les
deux mandats de barack obama le premier
mandat avait été quand même marqué par
la crise de 2008-2010
il y avait eu avant les deux mandats de
george w bush et le dernier mandat avait
aussi été affecté par la crise de 2010
mais si on prend par exemple le meilleur
mandats de george bush le meilleur
mandat de barack obama est bien on
obtient des taux de croissance qui sont
inférieurs aux taux de croissance qui
ont été obtenus dans les grosso modo
trois premières années du mandat de
donald trump donc oui effectivement sur
la croissance donald trump a comme on
dit fournit des résultats tout à fait
intéressant et comment cela s'est il
traduit concrètement pour les américains
alors pour les amériques à sa s'est
d'abord traduit par un niveau d'emploi
tout à fait important et ça c'est
quelque chose de très fondamentale si
vous voulez les statistiques de l'emploi
montrent que le taux de chômage alors
que ce soit le taux de chômage officiel
où que ce soit
le taux de chômage un petit peu dérivé
qui regardent plutôt l'emploi précaire
et l'emploi des des personnes qui sont
en dessous d'un mi-temps bon que ce quel
que soit l'indicateur que l'on utilise
et bien là on voit que très clairement
le taux de chômage a fortement baissé et
que à la fin de 2019 au début de 2020 en
réalité on était arrivés sous donald
trump
à des taux d'emploi qui était supérieur
au taux d'emploi qui avait pu être ce
que ce soit sous george bush ou
évidemment sous barack obama et même
sous clinton
donc il y a à l'évidence un succès la de
donald trump alors pourtant jacques il
ya eu des mesures qui ont davantage
avantages et les grandes fortunes comme
la réforme fiscale par exemple
oui c'est évident c'est évident et dès
donald trump a pris une réforme fiscale
qui a énormément avantager les plus
riches qui a comme on dit a avantagé au
wall street contre mainstreet bon
maintenant il faut qu'on avait un petit
peu modérer ce jugement en rappelant qu'
une grande partie de la classe moyenne à
travers les fonds de pension et bien
elle retrouve son intérêt dans la hausse
de wall street une hausse qui était
absolument spectaculaire et là encore si
vous voulez un point est intéressant
parmi les électeurs des deux camps 48%
considérer que leur situation était
meilleure en 2020 en dépit de la crise
yoko vide qu'elle n'était en 2016 alors
ce qui est intéressant c'est que sur ses
48 % qui pensaient que leur situation
s'était améliorée
72 % avaient voté pour donald trump et
26% pour joe biden alors japan on a
aussi beaucoup parlé de cette action de
donald trump par rapport aux traités
multilatéraux quel bilan auquel ville en
aep le temps alors en tirer
effectivement c'était un point important
dans la politique de donald trump et là
il ya plusieurs choses à dire la
première c'est que effectivement donald
trump s'est retirée du traité
transatlantique à ce qu'on appelle le
taffetas il l'a provoqué une
renégociation de ce qu'on appelle le
traité de libre échange de l'amérique du
nord l'alena ou en américain le naphta
et pointent encore plus important et
c'est peut-être le point qui avait donné
le plus d'espoirs aux gens il avait
introduit une clause de salaire minimum
de manière à pouvoir justement contrer
les pratiques de dumping social donc de
ce point de vue là il a fait pour le
coup là des choses plus tôt
positive alors mais il n'est pas seul
imagine jacques wi fi gure il ya
d'autres aspects qui sont des aspects
plus négative alors le premier aspect
plus négative évidemment c'est la
politique des sanctions et la politique
très unilatérale menée par donald trump
en continuité là il faut quand même le
souligner avec la politique qu'ils
avaient mais qui avait été menée par
barack obama
et puis surtout il y a le conflit
commercial avec la chine
un conflit qui a été extrêmement
important on est arrivé entre les deux
pays à une forme de trêve ou de paix
armée avec l'accord qui a été signé à la
fin de 2019
bien sûr les états unis ont obtenu
quelques avantages mais ça a été très
loin d'être tous qu'ils avaient voulu et
on comprend que sur ce point on restera
dans une situation extrêmement
conflictuel avec la chine
certainement dans le cadre du mandat de
joe biden et des mandats successifs
alors joe biden va-t-il prendre le
contre-pied de tout ce qu'a fait donald
trump ce actuellement s'il voulait
surtout sur toute une série de points
il est très clair que joe biden voudra
marquer sa différence avec donald trump
d'où effectivement le décret sur le
retour dans l'accord de paris mais sur
le fond il faut bien comprendre que ça
va se jouer autour de deux choses qui
sont extrêmement importantes
le premier point c'est qu'elle relance
ou quel soutien apporté à l'économie
américaine qui est aujourd'hui
extrêmement affecté par la crise de
lakovic 19 et là on voit que les deux
présidents enfin donald trump et joe
biden était d'accord pour apporter un
soutien important
après ils différaient sur son ampleur
sur les méthodes on sait que donald
trump était partisan d'un chèque envoyé
à toutes les familles américaines à
chèque de 2000 $ les démocrates et joba
eden et ont d'autres idées
ils veulent plutôt jouer
une relance structurelles bref mais il
ya à l'évidence la 1.1 point important
et puis l'autre chose qui est importante
c'est que joe biden a proposé de
soutenir les petites entre les petites
et moyennes entreprises american art
c'est une très bonne idée
il faut le dire tout de suite parce que
ce sont des entreprises qui ont besoin
surtout après tous les avantages qu'ils
ont été données aux grandes entreprises
d'avoir d'une certaine manière un espèce
de d'argent 22 ballon d'oxygène
aujourd'hui le point qui est gênant dans
la politique de joe biden c'est qu'il
voudrait justement favoriser plutôt les
petites et les moyennes entreprises qui
appartiennent à des minorités
alors il vise évidemment les petites et
moyennes entreprises de la minorité
hispanique de la minorité
afro-américaine et ça si vous voulez ça
risque de créer un problème politique
sur quelque chose qui devrait être en
réalité très consensuel parce que je ne
vois pas d'américain s'opposer à cette
aide à des petites et des moyennes
entreprises et donc tu sois en créant un
problème politique là où il ne devrait
pas y en avoir
c'est dommage et on peut penser que joe
biden risque de compromettre justement
cette action de relance alors à conclure
comment jugez vous le bilan économique
de donald trump à 7,1 pile en demi
teinte surtout par ailleurs si on
regarde les promesses qui avaient été
faites par donald trump lors de la
campagne de 2015 2016 si vous voulez
alors oui on ce qui concerne la
croissance et le chômage selon
l'expression américaine
il a fait le job il a trés trés de
manière très évidente fourni de bons
résultats si on commence à regarder la
question du commerce international et
des relations avec la chine
bon là on voit que le bilan est
peut-être plus en demi teinte
il n'est pas allé jusqu où il voulait
aller
il n'a pas été du tout capable
d'inverser le mouvement
déclin des états unis qui sont
aujourd'hui dépassés par la chine comme
première puissance économique mondiale
et rappelons nous son slogan de
2015-2016 refaire des états unis
redonner leur grandeur aux états unis
vous avez mec américaine
great games à dallas de fait il n'y est
pas il n'y est pas parvenu et
effectivement peut-être le point le plus
délicat dans ce bilan c'est le rapport
qu'il entretient entre à la fois les
très grandes entreprises les gens très
riches et les gens qui sont beaucoup
moins riches et les légendes de l'âme de
la classe moyenne
et là on peut dire qu'il n'a pas eu une
politique cohérente avec son discours
qui était un discours de populisme
économique du moins en 2015 et en 2016
ce qui veut dire que la question du
populisme économique qu'ils soient mises
en oeuvre par un futur candidat
républicain où un candidat à la
candidature républicaine où qu'il soit
mis en oeuvre par des démocrates et bien
cette question reste toujours posée aux
états unis merci beaucoup j'ai pensé
éclairage temps sur le milan sur les
défis qui attendent le maiden merci à
vous